[Música]
los japoneses ya tomaron una decisión
aunque encuesta reciente sugerían que
hasta el 40 por ciento de los votantes
seguían indecisos de cara a las
elecciones generales de este domingo una
de las preguntas al cierre es si la
participación entre los jóvenes fue
particularmente baja con otros partidos
solo están jugando por obtener votos no
puedo dejarles el país en este momento
solo el partido liberal democrático es
lo suficientemente bueno pero no estoy
emocionado por eso
no creo que haya un gran cambio
inmediato elegí un partido que parece
poner énfasis en mejorar la vida
cotidiana de las personas
donato pero más grande más
se espera que el partido
liberal-democrático que ha ocupado el
poder casi continuamente desde la década
de 1950 obtenga la mayoría de no poder
hacerlo sólo puede contar con la ayuda
de su socio de coalición pero se espera
que el pl de pierde escaños ante una
oposición más unida durante la corta
campaña que duró un par de semanas el
primer ministro fumio kishida se centró
en las medidas de respuesta ante el
joven 19 y en la reactivación económica
asumió el cargo hace un mes después de
que ellos y the sugar renunciara tras
estar solo un año en el cargo los
índices de aprobación de quisiera han
sido los más bajos en dos décadas para
una administración en japón si su
partido pierde muchos escaños esto
podría llevar a luchas internas y llevar
de nuevo al país a tener líderes por
periodos muy cortos como sucedió antes
de la llegada de shinzo abe